KYLE MORRISON: I grew up with
dogs my whole life used them
for hunting.
And hunting for explosives
or hunting for other animals
is very similar.
I wanted a dog that's
good with people
that I can work,
large venues around,
large gatherings of people.
So that's-- that
was very important.
That he be social.
I'm with him 40, 50 hours a week
while working and also at home.
He's in my house.
So at home he's just
like my other dogs.
He's free in the house.
Obviously we need that
relationship because I need
to know if he's--
how he's working that day.
We use the term "it
runs down leash."
So he senses if I'm
stressed or I'm upset.
It runs right down
the leash to him.
So it really is a dog team.
SHELBY SMITH: Canine Companions
actually matches them for us.
So they matched
Picasso and I based
on what they thought
was the best fit
and how he would work for me.
They got it right (LAUGHING).
That's for sure.
Picasso to me is just
more than independence,
he's my best friend.
He's somebody and
lean on, depend on
to get through daily
challenges that
comes with having a disability.
So he's just my whole world.